because Tom you often you're often
you're sporting and sometimes a big
beard recently you had a very you know
the thing about beards is they're really
fun to grow for a while there I am at
stagecoach just not to of long ago it's
really great to grow a beard until you
find yourself at dinner absent-mindedly
combing it with a fork that's very
interesting your majesty so when did you
too far stagecoach where you know you're
you've got you got a beer but you're
still obviously you're still obviously
you know Tom Hanks and let's see you're
in middle age I am a middle aged guy but
but you still had problems oh dear oh my
lord okay the great thing about these
outdoor festivals like like like
stagecoach or operate Coachella
Coachella you know it's really hot and
they have beer pavilions everywhere and
so we were there and it was like it was
it was read Assange at like 1:30
afternoon at about 110 I decided to go
get myself a frosty cold one and I went
on and said hi are you doing and I give
him a couple of seconds to let the
h-bomb drop like that come on yes huh
well Tom X yeah hi how are you nice you
could I have a draw please oh we sure
could we see your ID bracelet then I
said first of all you know my name and
secondly I'd like a beer says well we
can't sell you a beer without proof of
ID
I mean like so that I'm old enough to
afford but we just are not allowed to
give you a beer unless you have your ID
band sir I said well where do you get
your ID ban well it's about a half a
mile on the other side of I said look
not only am i who you think I am
I'm also sixty two goddamn years I would
really like to have it these ladies were
not allowed to sell me a beer without my
official stagecoach I am over 21 ID
break I did not have a beer until
somebody went over and got me and I and
I warned them I said listen ladies they
were a bit chagrined even the manager
says I'm so sorry but if I give you a
beer I'm just going to get fired I said
well this is going to make a great story
on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]